[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau date année
d'interdire pour une heure de
philosophie savante nous avons en effet
passé toute cette émission a parlé
métaphysique avec le philosophe francis
wolff professeur émérite à l'école
normale supérieure son livre le plus
important dire le monde publié pour la
première fois en 1997 sera en poche chez
plurielles dans une édition augmentée
bonjour francis wolff
qu'est-ce qu'est ce qui existe
réellement en quoi ce genre de question
mérite t'elle encore et toujours d'être
posée ça mérite d'être posée parce que
nous ne savons pas ce qu'il ya
réellement si nous savions eh bien nous
ne produirions plus la question est non
seulement la métaphysique s'arrêterait
ce qui ne serait sans doute pas très
dommageable mais la science elle-même
s'arrêterait ne et ne cessent de se
poser la question elle ne cesse d'y
répondre autrement vous avez sans doute
entendu qu'il ya quelques années il ya
une grande découverte
le boson de higgs existe alors
évidemment ça ne vous a pas changé votre
vie quotidienne mais c'était une grande
révolution sur la culture de la question
qu'est ce qui existe réellement
réellement en fait il ya peut-être que
du boson de x et peut-être que vous et
moi ne sommes qu'à un tas d'acides
aminés nous ne sommes peut-être rien
d'autre que des rêves dans l'esprit
malade
d'un dieu et tour dit je ne sais pas en
tout cas c'est une question qui existent
elles réellement et que nous ne pouvons
pas ne pas nous poser ne serait ce que
parce que nous avons tous une idée
autour de questions comme est ce que
dieu existe est ce que mon âme existe
est ce que mes ancêtres continue
d'exister bref c'est une question qui
alimente en permanence ce que nous
appelons l'humanité et que nous ne
devons pas je crois laissé seulement aux
physiciens aux biologistes mais pour
lesquels les philosophes aussi doivent
avoir leur mot à dire qui et c'est le
langage qui fait le réel vous nous
parler du besoin de x c'est parce que
vous le nommez qu'il existe à je crois
que ya un peu plus d'an dans le cas du
boson de higgs dont je ne suis pas
vraiment un spécialiste je crois qu'il
est un peu plus que le nom qui permet de
détecter les apparitions de la chose en
question mais il est clair que une des
thèses que je soutiens dans ce livre
dire le monde sait que c'est ce qui fait
du réel pour nous pour vous et moi qui
sommes des êtres humains ce qui fait que
leur elle nous apparaît comme un monde
c'est à dire comme quelque chose qui est
ordonnée structurés organisés et bien
c'est le langage le langage c'est une
formule que j'emploie souvent fait du
réel un monde et si nous n'avions pas le
langage si nous n'avions pas le langage
pour organiser le réel et bien nous
n'aurions chacun d'entre nous vivre est
peut-être comme certains animaux
certains mammifères dans un petit bout
de réelles pas très organisés en tout
cas qui ne ferait pas une totalité
organisée nous appelons un monde
mais est-ce que tout est langage ah non
bien sûr que non et à des choses qui ne
sont pas langage par exemple la
perception par exemple la conscience la
conscience ne se réduit pas au langage
ce que nous voyons ce que nous sentons
que nous touchons ça n'est pas du
langage il ya encore d'autres choses qui
ne sont pas du langage par exemple
justement les découvertes que sont les
scientifiques les physiciens ne se
ramène pas des effets de langage ils
sont le fruit de l'expérimentation ils
sont le fruit de l'interrogation que
nous pouvons faire à la nature ce qui
est langage ce qui est langage et que je
distingue du réel c'est le monde et je
répète je ne sais pas ce qui est réel et
les sciences s'évertue à le rechercher
le problème c'est que les sciences sont
plurielles et que la réponse que me
donne un biologiste et encore tel type
de biologistes n'est pas la même que
celle que me donne un physicien qui
n'est pas la même que celle que me donne
cosmologistes selon certains physiciens
bien le temps par exemple n'est pas réel
selon d'autres
ce qu'il y a de réelles et bien c'est
des atomes des bosons des frémion etc
et tout cela ne fait pas quelque chose
d'organisé et je le répète ce qui fait
que le réel pourtant nous apparaît à
nous comme quelque chose d'organisé
d'ordonner de total d'unifier et dont
nous pouvons vous et moi nous entretenir
par exemple en ce moment et bien c'est
le langage et jeudi définit le monde non
pas comme étant la réalité parce que la
réalité on ne cesse de la chercher je
définis le monde comme un ordre
total est commun un ordre c'est à dire
quelque chose qui forment un total y ait
bien fait en données totales parce que
y'a rien hors du monde est commun parce
que vous et moi et tous les êtres
parlants
au fond nous vivons dans le même monde
est ce que nous vivons dans le même
monde francis wolff à partir du moment
où certains vont avoir 300 mots de
vocabulaire
ceux qui essayent de parler une langue
qui n'est pas la leur par exemple ceux
qui ont trois mille mots de vocabulaire
ceux qui en ont trente mille alors je ne
je ne dirais pas que dans ces trois cas
les êtres humains en question ont une
expérience aussi riche non pas une même
façon de se référer à leurs propres
émotions et donc une partie de leurs
émotions leur semble étrange innommable
quand vous lisez des grands écrivains
non seulement qu'ils ont plus de
vocabulaire que vous et moi mais surtout
qu'ils ont des tours de langage de
syntaxe qui leur permettent de dire des
choses telles que lorsque vous les lisez
que vous les entendez vous avez le
sentiment que ce sentiment là justement
vous l'avez réellement éprouvée par ce
qu'il a réussi à mettre des mots sur des
sentiments que vous avez prouvé et que
vous n'auriez pas été capable de nommer
donc que vous ne seriez même pas que
vous les avez réellement éprouvé alors
ça c'est le pouvoir en effet du langage
est la différence entre un langage de 30
mille maux et surtout d'une très grande
richesse d'expression et de syntaxe et à
vocabulaire extrêmement pauvre mais
n'est en n'ayant dès lors qu'il y a
language riche ou pauvre
dès lors qu'il y as langage même chez le
petit enfant qui apprend à parler et
bien nous vivons dans le même monde et
je vais même aller plus loin avant le
langage au moment où les choses se
déclenche pour le petit d'homme vers
l'âge disons de 9 points en un an et
demi cetera
il est déjà dans le langage il est déjà
dans le monde il est déjà dans notre
monde humain il y a quelque chose de
très intéressant qu'on découvert un
certain nombre d'entrepôts log ou de
psychologues du développement qu'on
appelle l'attention partager et bien
vous vous mettez
primates quelconque oui avec une balle
au milieu bien et pourront s'en empare
et éventuellement jouer avec me vous
n'aurez pas quelque chose qui est propre
à l'humanité et qui est le fait qu'ils
se forment un triangle entre les deux
bébés si je puis dire et la balle qui
est au milieu c'est que vous avez le
regard qu'il va du regard de l'autre à
la balle et de là-bas le regard de
l'autre ils sont attentifs à la même
chose ils sont attentifs aux mêmes
objets et c'est comme si déjà il pouvait
en parler il y à ce triangle près
linguistique dans le qui est un de le
triangle qui définit à mon avis
l'humanité et qui fait que au fond ils
sont ses deux bébés déjà dans le même
monde dans un monde dont fait partie
cette balle et 7 balles dont ils ne
peuvent pas encore parlé mais qui est
entre eux comme l'objet commun et bien
ça c'est une chose que nous n'avons pas
dans les mondes animaux nous n'avons pas
ce partage a priori des choses dont ils
ne peuvent pas encore parlé mais à
propos desquels ils peuvent déjà échangé
leurs regards alors voyez vous avez un
vocabulaire l'acquis si pauvre qu'il
n'est que encore virtuel et pourtant ils
sont déjà dans le monde ils sont déjà
dans le même monde ils sont déjà dans un
monde objectif puisque ils partagent
entre les choses du monde
alors cette balle cette chaise papa
maman tout ce que vous voulez et bien
tout ça s'organise pour eux d'une façon
qui n'est plus simplement subjective
mais qui est déjà objective
tout est langage mais est-ce que tout
ait confiance alors il y a eu un courant
de la philosophie notamment en france et
en allemagne un petit peu au xxème
siècle qu'on appelait la phénoménologie
qui a voulu je vais simplifier au
maximum réduire tout ce que nous
pouvions savoir du monde à la conscience
que nous en avions et parmi les plus
célèbres en france d'une certaine
manière sartre
jean paul sartre était l'héritier de ce
courant phénoménologie cas il a écrit
des textes très important sur la
conscience et font la conscience a été
le centre de tout et le point de départ
de tout y compris autour de la question
qui était la question au fond la même
celle de sartre la section de l'être et
le néant
autrement dit la question qu'est ce qui
existe réellement qu'est-ce qui
n'existent pas eh bien le point de
départ qui est le mien n'est pas la
conscience c'est le langage parce que la
grande différence est ce qui est le fil
conducteur d'un grand nombre de médecins
certains de mes recherches c'est que la
conscience elle vous est propre
vous avez votre conscience qu'on appelle
la conscience psychologique c'est à dire
tout ce qui se passe en vous et que vous
pouvez penser
vous avez en ce moment des états de
conscience qui sont les vôtres et que je
ne peux pas partagé par définition
puisque je n'ai accès qu'à une
conscience la mienne et chacun un accès
qu'à une conscience la sienne alors que
le langage c'est que ce qui fait que
nous avons quelque chose en commun quoi
et bien le monde
la conscience ne nous donne pas un monde
si je puis dire propres alors que le
langage nous donne accès au monde commun
au monde partager au monde que tous les
êtres
je dis bien tous les êtres humains même
ceux qui n'ont pas la même langue
peuvent partager parce que toutes les
langues sont traduisible mais la
conscience peut elle se passer du
langage alors c'est une question très
discuté il y a si vous voulez deux
thèses qui s'affrontent
qu y compris aujourd'hui du point de vue
des neurosciences ou du point de vue des
linguistes
il ya ceux qui pensent que sans langage
nous aurions quand même des formes de
conscience qui seraient à peu près
semblable à celle que nous avons et
d'autres qui pensent qu'en fait c'est
le langage qui organise notre conscience
alors sans trancher dans le débat qui
devient assez vite assez technique
ce que je pense que je crois qu'on peut
dire c'est que ce dont nous avons
conscience
nous en avons une conscience simplement
je dirais flou imprécise indécise tant
que nous n'avons pas été capables de
mettre des mots sur ce que nous promet
prouvons ce que nous sentons ce que nous
percevons est bien autrement dit là
encore c'est le langage qui permet à la
conscience de devenir une conscience
claire distingue réfléchi et d'ailleurs
lorsque vous présentez des choses
consciemment mais que vous ne pouvez pas
les dire
vous ressentez un manque qui peut-être
et le manque de beaux mots ou le monde
le manque de mots et leur pouvoir
d'expression mais vous ressentez qu'il
manque quelque chose à la conscience
même que vous que vous avez de la chose
en question
donc je pense que il y à un surcroît que
donne le langage à la conscience
elle-même
est-ce que tout est histoire c'est à
dire est-ce que tout peut peut t'on
penser hors de l'histoire alors c'est
une autre question vous avez tout à fait
raison il y a une il y a en effet
beaucoup de philosophes qui ont pu
soutenir que certains ont pu soutenir
que tout ait conscience parce que sont
la conscience et bien nous n'aurions pas
ce sentiment d'organisation du tout dont
je parlais à l'instant tout est langage
ça n'est pas exactement ce que je
soutiens je soutiens que le monde est
organisé comme un langage mais tout est
histoire oui d'une certaine manière mais
c'est pas le même tout c'est pas le même
tout dont on parle dans tous les cas
qu'est ce que ça peut vouloir dire tout
est histoire cela peut signifier la
chose suivante il n'y a rien dont on ne
puisse
et que l'on ne puisse prendre pour un
objet de réflexion ou de pensée qui
n'est une certaine épaisseur historique
toutes nos idées que nous pensons être
éternelle ou que nous pensons absolument
vrai elles sont lestés par leur date de
naissance elles sont lestés par le fait
qu'elles appartiennent un courant une
histoire alors c'est la même chose que
les gens qui disent tout et culture
bien entendu une idée est la l1 lieu de
naissance qui la culture dans laquelle
elle est née est la date de naissance
qui ça date historique
elle est éphémère comme toute idée mais
néanmoins je crois que ça n'est pas dans
le même sens que moi je dis tout est
langage au plus juste où je dis pas que
tout est langage jeudi que le tout forme
un tout parce que nous pouvons
l'appréhender parle le langage c'est à
dire je le répète c'est le monde dont je
dis qu'il est structuré comme un langage
tout est histoire ça n'est pas dans le
même sens mais si vous allez voir un
historia il vous dira qu'en un sens
c'est vrai que pour lui tout est
histoire c'est à dire tout et il va vous
montrer derrière tout objet que vous
pensez hors de l'histoire il va vous
montrer son épaisseur historique qui va
aller vous montrer comme une archive et
bien vous pouvez les changer
d'interlocuteur vous allez voir un
sociologue real sociologue dû accueillir
des noms l'historien se trompe tout
n'est pas histoire tout est social doute
et sociale d'une épaisseur sociale dans
tout ce qui existe dans tout ce qui se
fait au fond même il vous dira il n'y a
pas de nature les sexes ce ne sont pas
ils ne sont pas naturels il n'y a que
des sexes qui sont sociaux et qui se
révèle n'être que des rôles sociaux dont
qu'on appelle des genres aujourd'hui le
masculin et le féminin
bref tout est social tout est histoire
tout cela c'est vrai tout et conscience
tout cela est vrai mais ce n'est pas le
même tout ce dont on parle c'est d'un
pas la même façon d'additionner les
choses et ce que je soutiens
c'est que le monde humain comme tel
le monde dans lequel vous vivez vous et
moi dans lequel nous vivons vous et moi
et dans lequel tous les humains vivent
en dépit du fait qu'ils n'ont pas la
même condition historique qui n'ont pas
la même condition sociale qui n'ont pas
la même conscience et bien qu'il le
veuille ou non il partage le même monde
oui mais alors selon la langue que l'on
parle le monde ne change t'il pas oui
c'est une thèse là encore qui a pu être
soutenu
c'est celle qu'on appelle du relativisme
linguistique le relativisme linguistique
c'est une thèse assez forte
alors il ya des nuances mais certains
ont pu soutenir que selon la langue que
vous parlez le monde est structurée
d'une façon différente
alors il ya des exemples qui sont très
discutée par exemple combien y at-il de
couleurs de l'arc en ciel
eh bien on va vous dire ben dans
certaines langues lien il ya cette
couleur à essentiel donc on voit cette
couleur dans l'arc en ciel
il yad'autres vous avez infiniment plus
de noms de couleurs et donc les gens
verront plus de couleurs de l'arc en
ciel
alors vous voyez de la neige parce que
vous n'êtes pas un grand spécialiste de
la neige mais on nous explique que si
vous parliez telle langue eskimos vous
ne riez vous ne verriez pas de la neige
ou guerrier dix ou quinze sortes de
choses différentes parce que vous auriez
10 ou 15 mots différents pour pour
désigner la neige pont alors évidemment
quand on fait du ski on peut se dire que
on ne confond pas la poudreuse la soupe
la profondeur et c'est donc les usagers
ne vivent pas dans la même neige les
usagers de la neige ne vivent pas la
même taille
je pense néanmoins qu'ils vivent que
nous vivons usagers ou non de la neige
nous vivons quand même où ce qui est
heureux ou non nous vivons quand même
dans le même monde au sens large du
terme c'est-à-dire un arbre total est
commun mais pour revenir à cette thèse
du relativisme linguistique
c'est une thèse qui est très fort très
intéressante et je ne crois pas que l'on
puisse aller jusqu'à dire qu'il y à un
monde par l'ong
pourquoi parce que ce qui m'intéresse
c'est ce qui intéressait aussi quelques
autres philosophes du langage ou de la
linguistique c'est qu'il y a des
universaux dans le langage que quelle
que soit la langue que vous parlez et je
parle pas simplement des langues très
proches comme les langues
indo-européennes mais des langues très
éloigné de certaines langues africaines
ou où certaines langues asiatiques qui
n'ont aucun rapport avec celle que nous
connaissons ordinairement et bien vous
avez des constantes vous avez des
universaux etc sucer universo qui
structurent à mon avis le monde et un
des universaux des structures
universelle qui m'a le plus intéressé
c'est mais pas moi qu'ils aient
découvert c'est
notre père à tous c'est à dire que vous
savez aristote qui a découvert cet
universel c'est ce qui c'est ce qu'on a
appelé la prédication
alors ça c'est quelque chose de très
intéressant c'est que je prenais tout à
l'heure l'exemple des deux bébés face à
une même un même objet par exemple une
balle quand nous avons quand nous avons
l'intention de parler d'un objet vous et
moi par exemple cet extraordinaire livre
que je tiens dans mes pains et bien
lorsque nous avons cette intention vous
pourriez dire sur l'italie vous pourriez
dire oh oui j'ai lu ce lui seul il n'est
pas très bon alors moi je vous
répondrais si si quand même il est
absolument excellent alors qu'est ce que
nous venons de faire nous venons de nous
contredire n'a l'autre nous parlons de
la même chose alors c'est quelque chose
qui est absolument essentiel ou langages
absolument essentiel à toute langue
quelle qu'elle soit qu'elles soient
proches ou non de la nôtre c'est que
nous avons nécessairement pour
communiquer besoin de parler de la même
chose cette chose que je montre cette
chose qui occupait déjà le regard comme
un de nous deux bébés tout à l'heure
enfin il parlait pas de mon mon bouquin
il parlait d'une balle mais peu importe
en fait ils en parlaient pas encore mais
il l'avait à l'oeil et donc nous parlons
d'une chose d'une même chose et pourtant
nous en disent ont des choses contraires
il est bon il est mauvais c'est la
condition même pour que y ait un
dialogue et c'est là qu'on ose enfin
c'est la condition c'est les deux
conditions pour qu'il y ait un dialogue
possible c'est les deux conditions qui
structurent tout langage humain quelles
conditions et bien que nous puissions
parler d'une seule et même chose cette
chose là la même pour vous et moi et que
nous partageons et qui fait partie du
monde voilà elle fait partie du monde
c'est à dire elle ne dépend pas de vous
et dépend pas de moi ce jeu génère
d'enfoncer des portes ouvertes mais
c'est quelque chose d'essentiel
et elle elle est entre nous elle est
objectivement dans le monde cette chose
et pourtant elle est la même pour tous
les deux mais nous n'avons pas le même
jugement à ce propos eh bien il faut que
le monde soit sur twitter et d'une façon
à ce que nous puissions à la fois parler
de la même chose qu'on appelle sujet de
notre discours commun et que nous
puissions lui attribuer un prédicat se
tait exemple predica bon mot mais alors
nous sommes en contradiction sur le
prédicat à la seule condition que nous
soyons d'accord sur le sujet et bien ça
c'est une structure du langage
extraordinairement riche qui est
évidemment propre à l'humanité et qui
nous permet de parler de toutes les
choses du monde parce et ce pour ce
pouvoir extraordinaire
il permet à la fois que nous parlions de
la même chose et n'importe quoi du
soleil qui s'est levé ce matin delà de
la maison de tout ce que vous avez fait
de quoi mieux au fur et à mesure de la
journée que nous puissions parler du
monde et que nous puissions en dire des
choses opposées alors que même que nous
vivons dans le même monde
cette structure qu'on appelle la
prédication parler de quelque chose et
pouvoir en dire quelque chose
cette différence entre sujet predica le
fait qu'un même sujet peut avoir des
prédicats opposé est extrêmement riche
parce qu'elle nous permet aussi de
penser le temps pensé le temps par
exemple si vous dites que ce livre est
bien il est un peu abîmée il ne l'était
pas donc je pouvais je vais pouvoir
parler d'une seule et même chose et dire
qu'elles changent avec le temps ou si je
ne vous ai pas vus depuis quelques
années je pourrais vous dire ah mais
comme tu as changé
mais pour que je puisse dire que tu as
changé il faut
encore que je vous reconnaisse comme
n'ayant pas changé ici je puis dire dire
que vous êtes toujours le même et bien
cette possibilité là encore c'est la
prédication parle d'une chose et on dit
qu'elle n'est plus la même et c'est ce
qu'on appelle le temps le temps qui nous
permet de dire qu'une chose demeure ce
qu'elle est
tout en ayant des prédicats ou
qualificatifs opposé un tel était jeune
il est vieux intel était en bonne santé
il est malade
bref si nous n'avions pas cette
possibilité bien le monde nous
paraîtrait absolument au présent et ça
encore capacités nous avons de parler
d'un monde en permanence changeant est
due à cette structure du langage quand
je pense qu'elle est extrêmement riche
qu'elle est je reviens à votre question
quelle est commune à toutes les langues
humaines
elle est nécessairement commune à toutes
les langues humaines parce que toutes
langues humaines nécessite la
communication sinon ce ne serait pas une
langue et elle et elle les communes
simplement hollandaise humaine je veux
dire par là
il est de mode aujourd'hui
depuis quelques années de dire que les
animaux sont des êtres absolument
extraordinaire ils ont toutes les mêmes
capacités que nous ils ont des capacités
de langage extraordinaire et c'est bon
neu neu neu blé sont pas la sensibilité
de ce qu'il pense mais il est vrai que
les animaux sociaux on le sait depuis
fort longtemps des capacités
d'expression et de communication
extrêmement riche mais ils n'ont pas la
structure prédictive c'est à dire que si
vous supposez qu'un animal même
extrêmement intelligent car tout cela
n'a aucun appareil intelligent ce qu'un
animal même extrêmement intelligent à la
capacité de parler de dix choses 50
choses sans show 200 choses autant que
vous voulez et bien il ne pourra pas
aller au delà de dire
chacune de ces choses alors que
en bénéficiant de la structure de la
prédication entre autres nous avons la
possibilité non pas de parler de 10 20
50 ou 100 choses même 1000 mhz et d'une
infinité de choses s'interrompt francis
vals enfin on fait une pause et il a
tout de suite après
[Musique]
nous continuons cette émission avec le
philosophe francis wolff son aisselle
plus célèbres dire le monde ressort en
poche chez plurielles dans une édition
augmentée vous mais on s'est arrêté
juste au moment où j'allais vous posez
la question qui allait de soi derrière
le monde peut-il être contradictoires
c'est ce qu'a l'air de de laisser
entendre
l'idée du de la prédication vous venez
de vous expliquer eh bien nous pouvons
nous contredire l'un l'autre même nous
avons cette possibilité extraordinaire
qui s'appelle le dialogue et dans
lesquels nous pouvons parler de la même
chose tout en disant des choses
contraires à son propos voilà ce qui
nous permet à la fois de nous distinguer
mais aussi de vivre dans le même monde
mais le monde lui-même lui même n'est
pas contradictoire
alors je vais essayer de le faire sentir
en me référant à une phrase que je
trouve très belle d'un philosophe qu'on
appelle présocratiques qui s'appelle
héraclite alors héraclite disait les
hommes qui dorment au chacun leur monde
mais les sommes éveillés ville dans le
même monde
alors c'est une phrase qui me semble
extrêmement juste et profonde parce que
cela implique en particulier que le
monde du rêve
le monde que chacun emporte avec soi ou
porte en soi
lorsqu'ils sont dors et contradictoires
mais dès que nous ouvrons les yeux et
bien la contradiction cesse je vais
essayer de me l'expliquer un peu plus ça
n'est pas l'irak liszt et freund qui
disait que le rêve ne connaît pas le
principe de contradiction
qu'est-ce que cela signifie cela
signifie qu par exemple vous rêvez
d'un personnage et puis ce personnage
c'est votre voisin de palier par exemple
mais en même temps c'est votre père ça
arrive en rêve
c'est évidemment quelque chose de
contradictoire parce que si c'est vous
le voisin de palier à moins que vous
viviez ce même palais votre père ce que
j'ignore tout puisque je ne sais même
pas sur quel pays vous habitez frédéric
mais en général dans le rêve ce sont
deux personnages qui se trouve dans un
sol et sur le moment du rêve
ça ne vous étonne pas du tout c'est à
dire que voilà c'est votre voisin et en
même temps c'est votre père il se peut
même d'ailleurs que la seconde d'après
ce soit en même temps votre cousin c'est
sur ces choses là arrivent en rêve ça ne
vous étonne pas ça ne vous choque pas et
le rêve continue et puis se passent les
choses les plus bizarres qui soit c'est
que ce même personnage qui en réalité
hakim on se met à vous parler de choses
qui ne pouvaient pas se connaître
tout cela ne vous étonne pas d'ordre
tout cela est contradictoire le rêve ne
connaît pas le principe de contradiction
ça signifie qu un même personnage peut à
la fois être votre père et ne pas être
votre père il peut être votre voisin de
palier et ne pas être votre voisin de
palier tout ça est possible en rêve et
donc nous pouvons sentir la
contradiction et ne pas la vivre comme
une contradiction ne pas la vivre dans
l'effroi que nous donnerait le monde si
les choses étaient à la fois ce qu'elles
sont et ce qu'elles ne sont pas alors
vous vous réveillez oui là je voulais
finir vous réveiller et puis vous allez
raconter à votre amie âgée fait art est
bizarre j'ai rêvé que tu vois le voisin
de palier où je vois un tel bond c'était
mon père en même temps alors raconté ça
mais dix ans à venir c'est bizarre parce
que je croyais qu'il m'avait dit que tu
avais pas vu ton père depuis maintenant
tout ça oui mais justement dans mon rêve
c'était tout à fait normal c'était mon
voisin de palier et s'est alors vous
voyez en même temps quand vous racontez
le rêve
vous allez être obligé de mettre le
doigt sur quelque chose qui au moment où
vous le racontez vous apparaît comme
contradictoires que la chose et et ne
pas et n'est pas en même temps la même
chose
c'est ça qui vous apparaît quand vous le
raconter parce que vous êtes obligés
d'employer des mots vous êtes obligés
d'employer des appellations pour les
choses keane qui sont communes à votre
interlocuteur est à vous même parce que
vous vivez comme lui dans le même monde
où votre père et votre père et ne peut
pas être non votre nom père ou autre
ou qui que ce soit d'autre donc quand on
se réveille et qu'on a la nécessité de
communiquer quelque chose qui est
contradictoire ça nous apparaît comme
une contradiction que nous n'avions pas
vécu sur le moment du rêve comme une
contradiction
donc ce que j'appelle le monde ce n'est
pas le monde que chacun porte en soi
fait ce que je disais au début à propos
de la conscience ce que j'appelle le
monde
c'est cet ordre total et commun que nous
partageons vous et moi et dans lequel
est bien les choses
les livres les verts que j'ai là le père
dont je parle le mien est décédé mais il
m'apparaît en rêve et ça ne m'étonne pas
du tout eh bien ce sont ils ne peuvent
pas être contradictoire dès lors que
j'en parle parce que sinon je ne
pourrais même pas en parler je ne
pourrais même pas parler d'un être
contradictoires francis wolff les
uchronies sont à la mode y en a de très
célèbres
ce sont des fictions il ya un célèbre
roman de philip roth sous ils
imaginaient que franklin roosevelt ne se
représentait pas au terme de son
deuxième mandat que c'était lindbergh
qui était élu que l'amérique d'être
antisémite et s'allier avec l'allemagne
nazie
on voit bien qu'à ce moment là on
bascule dans un autre monde mais il y a
sur cette terre et autour de vous des
gens qui croient que notre monde a été
créé par dieu en 16 7 jours et d'autres
qui n'y croient pas il ya des gens
aujourd'hui qui pensent que le coc vide
19 n'existe pas et d'autres qui pensent
qu'il existe il ya des gens qui pensent
que bill gates veut insérer dans les
vaccins des puces qui nous contrôlerons
est ce que nous vivons dans le même
monde
tous ensemble là alors que nous avons
des visions si radicalement opposées de
la même chose
disons que dès lors que
vous avez vous croyez en un certain
nombre de balles pas simplement de fake
news de complot mais le mythe de légende
bien entendu l'identité des choses
changent quand je dis l'identité
j'emploie exprès ce mot parce que la
plupart des contes et légendes et même
certains des mythes fondateurs de
certaines cultures comme le mythe selon
lesquelles dieu aurait créé et le monde
en sept jours dans lesquelles nous
descendons tous deux d'un même couple de
pêcheurs qui aurait mangé la pomme etc
cela nous définit les uns les eaux d'une
façon différente chaque peuple a besoin
de se définir définir son identité par
des mythes par des croyances et il est
clair alors pour prendre maintenant pour
aller à l'autre bout de l'échelle
historique pour prendre les choses
parlent par le même côté que vous que
les personnes dont vous parlez et qui
ont ils se font une représentation
extrêmement méfiante des apports de la
raison humaine et en particulier de la
raison scientifique de la qui par
exemple qu'ils nient ce qu'on appelle le
créationnisme pour prendre cet exemple
qui nie les apports de la théorie de
l'évolution darwinienne qui que donc le
monde humain à quelques centaines de
milliers d'années et que globe terrestre
lui même en a quelques millions ou
quelques centaines de millions bref ce
refus
de d'adhérer aux conquêtes des lumières
et de la rationalité fait que chacun a
alors c'est ce que j'appellerais son
petit bout de réels soucis vous de réel
et vous savez on parle et c'est freud
qui parlait du narcissisme des petites
différences c'est à dire que quand y'a
pas grand chose qui vous sépare de votre
voisin et que vous pensez que votre
voisin en fait il est très très
différent de vous parce qu'il n'a pas
tout à fait le même nez ou la même
couleur de peau et bien vous allez en
faire une montagne vous allez considérer
qu' on n'est pas les mêmes êtres humains
on n'a pas la même
on ne vit pas dans le même monde je
pense néanmoins que ces différences et
divergences que nous avons sur les
réalités et surtout sur les moyens
d'accéder au réel
n'empêche pas que nous vivons dans le
monde parfois évidemment je me dis que
j'aimerais bien ne pas partager le même
monde que certains imbéciles évidemment
que et que certaines qui est certaine
voilà que certaines additions qui est
certaine adhésion à certains théories
complotistes véhiculées par certains
médias qui évidemment entretiennent les
gens dans un certain nombre d'illusions
de croyance fausse je le regrette mais
hélas si je puis dire
nous faisons partie du même nom des
vis-à-vis de ces gens là si vous je les
croise demain bien je serai capable de
leur parler du la pluie et du beau temps
ce que je ne pourrais pas faire avec le
plus intelligent des primates
donc que nous le voulions nous nous
autres êtres humains et c'est un don une
autre de mes thèmes que j'ai développé
dans d'autres livres précédents
plaidoyer pour l'universel eh bien nous
sommes condamnés que nous le voulions ou
non à vivre dans le même monde et à
reconnaître tout autre être humain comme
absolument semblables à nous mêmes car
nous pouvons nous parler nous pouvons
nous énerver les uns contre les autres
en pensant que nous ne pensons pas la
même chose mais pour ne pas penser la
même chose
il faut que nous ayons quelque chose en
commun qui cette faculté de pouvoir
parler des choses et le monde
existe-t-il en soi ou bien des pentes il
de notre faculté à parler des choses la
vérité existe-t-elle alors la vérité
avec un grand v je n'y crois pas
beaucoup mais parme et partons des
choses les plus immédiates
j'ai vu je me suis réveillé de bonne
heure ce matin j'ai vu le soleil se
lever alors je vous dis ça je rencontre
un physicien du diable ce matin c'était
beau jeu le lever du soleil elle alors
ils répondent mais non chez à fond ses
hommes cette erreur le soleil ne se lève
pas vous savez bien que nous avons
abandonné depuis quelques siècles le
système géocentrique en un système
héliocentrique et c'est donc une
illusion
le soleil multi mobile c'est la terre
n'est ce pas qui tourne sur elle même et
qui vous a donné cette illusion très
bien alors on peut dire que à part ça le
système héliocentrique lui même est
illusoire parce que dans la théorie de
la relativité générale et bien on peut
montrer que
cela même d'un centre qui serait le
soleil est illusoire et c'est alors on
est ce qu'on peut en tirer
le fait que la vérité est relative aux
découvertes scientifiques et qu'elle
l'ait que en son approche peut-être
progressivement mais qu on ne l'atteint
jamais alors oui et non oui non en ce
sens que d'une certaine manière nous
nous pouvons dire qu'il y a des choses
vraies des propositions des thèses qui
sont vrais et d'autres et d'autres qui
sont simplement l'objet des meilleurs
théories scientifiques auxquels nous
pouvons accéder
je vous prendrai je vais prendre un
exemple peut-être un peu plus clair je
vous dis la neige et blanc j'ai parlé de
la neige tout à l'heure je vous dis la
neige et blanche c'est vrai c'est une
proposition absolument vrai et si par
hasard quelqu'un vous dit non là la
neige et et rouge ou verte vous dirais
que c'est faux et vous ou alors
peut-être qu'il a des problèmes de la
vision des couleurs et dans ces cas là
c'est un problème purement subjectif
mais objectivement nous pouvons dire que
la neige est blanche et que c'est une
proposition vraie objectivement nous
pouvons dire que deux plus de galles 4
c'est quelque chose qui est indéniable
qui est objectif et qui est même
démontrable ne pouvons dire que la somme
des angles d'un triangle est égale à
deux angles droits nous pouvons dire
énormément de choses qui sont absolument
indéniable et qui ne dépendent pas qui
ne sont pas subjective même si il est
clair que d'un autre point de vue c'est
à dire d'un point de vue physique vous
pouvez les composés la neige en disant
qu'au fond la neige en tant que
substance n'existe pas que ce sont que
des cristaux qui des cristaux purement
apparent vous dire que la blancheur
n'est qu'un effet et comme toutes les
couleurs ne sont qu'un effet de notre
système
notre système perceptif et qu'en réalité
il y as ni neige ni blancheur je pense
en tout cas que pour les besoins qui
sont les nôtres les besoins humains qui
sont des nôtres nos besoins vitaux nos
besoins des changes n'ont besoin de
communication le besoin perceptif il y à
des vérités et il y a des faussetés
il y a aussi des manières d'aborder le
réel qui recherchent le maximum de
cohérence entre la raison et
l'expérience et c'est ce qu'on appelle
les théories scientifiques
je crois que il ya une méfiance
aujourd'hui qui me paraît extrêmement
dangereuse vis-à-vis des théories
scientifiques parce que les théories
scientifiques porte forcément en elle la
marque de leur propre scepticisme par
rapport aux tireurs à leur propre
théorie mais celles ci sont toujours
infiniment plus ferme et stable que tous
les mythes par lesquels on veut ni
remplacer autrement dit il y à des
vérités pour le monde dans lequel nous
vivons
il ya des vérités partielles concernant
les réalités mais ces réalités nous les
atteignons le mieux par les meilleurs
théories scientifiques à notre
disposition il ya tout de même
même dans l'actualité des choses qui
pose problème francis balle je me donne
cet exemple un homme fait un enfant à sa
femme puis il devient une femme et sur
ses papiers il est une femme puisqu'il
est devenue une femme il en a les
attributs donc il devient une femme par
ses papiers et à sont là ils demandent à
la justice de reconnaître qu'il n'est
pas le père de l'enfant comme c'était le
cas jusque-là mais sa mère et quelle est
la vérité alors la justice lui dit non
vous pouvez pas être la mère alors que
vous êtes le père donc il vous faut
l'adopter et réponses mais pas adopter
mon propre enfant
vous voyez bien qu'on est parfois dans
des situations inextricables
[Rires]
je suis
je suis d'accord avec vous que le
progrès du droit le progrès des moeurs
l'évolution de notre sensibilité nous
mène à des contradictions en général
d'ailleurs les moeurs vont plus vite que
le droit pour prendre l'exemple que vous
avez des prix que et la science va plus
vite que les moeurs aussi puisqu'on a pu
élargir une femme avant même que ce soit
admis bien sûr la science et même les
techniques les techniques vont plus vite
que les moeurs on peut faire on ya
beaucoup de manières de faire des
enfants par différentes techniques avant
même que les moeurs les reconnaissent
dans tous les cas dans tous les pays et
le droit avance à son rythme pas trop
vite parce que le droit toujours quelque
chose de conservateurs mais bien entendu
ça mène à des contradictions comme celle
que vous dites c'est à dire que
d'apparentés contradictions car ce qui
est un impair en un sens c'est aussi une
mère en un autre sens
et puis vous savez il ya le père
biologique le père social et tout un tas
d'autres pères enfin tout cela n'est
d'ailleurs pas si nouveau que cela parce
que dre énormément de sociétés qu'on
appelle sans doute à tort des sociétés
primitives et bien le père sociale est
souvent l'oncle paternel et la mère
sociale et la mère la soeur de delà de
la mer et le rapport que les enfants
liés parce que l'idée qu' il ya une
famille éternel papa maman et les
enfants c'est un mythe moderne
relativement récent mais dans énormément
de civilisation de culture
le père sociale qui par exemple l'oncle
paternel a plus d'importance que le père
biologique du point de vue de
l'éducation de la transmission des
valeurs etc
francis wolff je vous interromps parce
qu'il nous reste quelques minutes et on
n'a pas abordé une question qui est très
importante dans votre livre c'est le
pourquoi
or on est à une époque on se pose
beaucoup de pourquoi quand on regarde le
monde quand on dit le monde
on veut comprendre pourquoi pourquoi on
est pauvre ou pourquoi on érige pourquoi
on est au chômage
autrefois on disait dieu l'a voulu
c'était beaucoup plus simple aujourd'hui
on va chercher le pourquoi et on y voit
alors selon les uns vont vous dire si
vous êtes pauvre c'est que vous l'avez
mérité au fond c'est vous êtes
responsable de vos actes d'autres vont
dire non si vous êtes pauvre c'est parce
que il ya des riches et qui vous ont
volé votre parc du gâteau etc etc
là encore comment résoudre le problème
selon vous bien déjà se poser la
question pourquoi c'est déjà faire un
pas qui nous mène hors de la fatalité ou
du fatalisme
quand on commence à se poser la question
pourquoi on a déjà fait la moitié du
chemin
je m'explique lorsque ce n'est jamais
pour prendre l'exemple qu'il prend celui
du pauvre et bien le pauvre qui colle à
sa pauvreté et qui ne se posent pas la
question de sa pauvreté parce que ça lui
apparaît quelque chose comme une
condition naturelle pas forcément parce
que dieu l'a voulu c'est une hypothèse
possible mais simplement parce que voilà
c'est comme ça c'est sa nature il n'y a
pas à se poser la question mais dès lors
qu'ils se posent la question il se
distancie par rapport à sa propre
condition qu'ils ne lui apparaît plus
comme naturelle comme collant à lui même
elle lui apparaît comme quelque chose de
détachable mot pauvre sa pauvreté lui
apparaît comme un objet d'interrogation
et comme un objet de perplexité et dès
lors selon les cas évidemment il pourra
s'engager dans la lutte syndicale ou la
lutte révolutionnaire ou au contraire
considérer
voilà qu'il n'ya qui nie qu'il n'y a pas
d'espoir immédiat pour lui ce qui nous
paraît important je les écris c'est que
les deux questions essentielles qui sont
propres à l'humanité qui sont des
questions tolère absolument métaphysique
on les retrouve y compris dans la vie
quotidienne c'est la question qu'est-ce
que et la question pourquoi est ce sont
les questions les plus importantes parce
qu'elle structure depuis le départ le
questionnement sans tain
quand vous entendez un petit enfant les
premières questions qu'ils posent ils me
savoir le nom de cheveux toute chose qu
est ce que c était ce que c'était ce que
c'est et c est un peu plus tard la
deuxième question qui se pose c'est
pourquoi alors voulu donner une réponse
et puis vous réponds et pourquoi et
pourquoi épervier finalement vous lui
dites bon ben ça suffit maintenant mange
ta soupe
enfin bref et vous ils pressent phare
c'est pourquoi répéter il perce il
perçoit quelque chose qui est
métaphysique
c'est qu' il n'y a pas de réponse ultime
atout c'est pourquoi et que c'est
pourquoi s'enchaînent et que toute
raison à nouveau une autre raison qui à
nouveau cet autre raison etc
c'est comme ça qu'on a inventé et bien
une cause première une cause de tout par
exemple dans certains civilisation
l'idée d'un dieu créateur dans d'autres
civilisations l'idée que le monde a été
fait par un diable et un bon dieu bref
qu'il y a des causes ultime est que le
mal par exemple pourquoi je souffre qui
est la question qu on trouve dans la
bible dans le livre de job et bien
qu'ils aient une réponse ultime parce
qu'elle du mal parce que rien parce
qu'il ya un diable parce qu'il ya
quelqu'un qui m'en veut qu'ils aient
l'esprit malin ou qui peut être mon
voisin mon voisin de palier dont je
parlais tout à l'heure
bref il y à déjà la danse est question
de l'enfant le pressentiment de quelque
chose qui est extrêmement profonds qui
est à l'origine de ce qu'il ya de plus
humain dans l'homme c'est à dire la
recherche
à la fois scientifique la recherche
métaphysique la rercherche religieuse
aussi le charme d'un sens à la vie est
en tout cas qui se posent la question
portons pourquoi je suis au chômage
pourquoi l'enfant que l'on punit
pourquoi lui et pas moi
pourquoi moi et pas lui plus exactement
et pourquoi j'ai plus que l'autre est
pourquoi untel est puni alors qu'il n'a
rien fait ou c'est pourquoi sont au
fondement et bien de l'éthique de la
physique de la métaphysique bref de tout
ce qui est humain en l'être humain et et
dès l'instant où l'enfant ou moi en tant
qu interviewer je vous pose la question
dès l'instant où dit je dis moi je au
fond la parole peut dire tout ce qu'il y
a dans le monde même ne peut jamais dire
le monde comme un tout dites vous oui
c'est en effet une des conclusions de ce
livre je distingue de façon de dire le
monde comme le titre du livre indique je
peux en parler d'une façon objective
détaché comme bas comme un physicien
comme un métaphysicien peut-être je vais
je me place hors du monde et j'essaie de
le décrire objectivement et de
l'expliquer objectivement sans y prendre
ma part mais dès lors que je dis je dès
lors que je dis moi dès lors que je
m'implique et bien tout change si je
puis dire c'est ce que j'appelle la
différence que je fais entre langage
monde parler des choses objectivement
parce que j'ai appelé tout à l'heure la
structure prédictive
voilà la neige et blanche le ballon et
rouge le livre est bon ou mauvais et
d'un autre côté la parole monde la part
allemande dans laquelle je me mets en
scène comme quelqu'un est dans ce cas là
tout change dans ce cas là tout change
parce que je pense à moi d'une toute
autre façon je pense que je suis un
esprit et quand je vous parle je pense
que vous êtes aussi
esprit que vous avez accès à votre
esprit de la même façon que moi j'ai
accès aux miens et dans ce cas là je ne
suis plus dans la structure que
j'appelle prédit cathy je suis dans une
autre structure qui permet
l'interlocution ses pairs comme un tu es
dans le monde du jeu et du tube il n'y a
plus du tout simplement la relation
objectifs que nous avons avec les choses
il y à un monde qui nous est commun à
vous et à moi dire le monde l'essai de
francis vol vient de ressortir en poche
chez plurielles dans une édition
augmentée
merci francis wolff d'avoir passé toute
cette émission avec nous merci de nous
avoir suivis et rendez vous au prochain
numéro
[Musique]